we now have a virtual presentation for
you so we're keeping our fingers crossed
that um all the technicals work out okay
it's another case study we heard one
earlier from mountains this one is from
michael brown from hydrogen east who all
being well will be on a screen near you
very soon we hope
so hopefully my virtual clicker will
work and you see the slides move along
so
yeah hydrogen east who are we so we
actually only just set up in may 2020.
again it's it's
the the primary role really was to get
talking about some of the opportunities
that
could be seen across the east of england
um looking at developing local supply
chains and markets
um and and getting the conversation
going a little bit more around hydrogen
we've been focused on a number of
specific projects across the region
um which i'll walk you through later
today but really what we want to see is
uptake across a range of sectors maybe
some initial demonstration projects over
the next few years
possibly across power heat buildings
transport
and businesses fundamentally as well
so
just to set the
uh the background around this so
there's been a rapidly developing
landscape not just
with hydrogen but more broadly with the
wider net zero debate over the past 18
24 months
so
this this slide really just sets out
that timeline how
in how we've seen it and across the
hydrogen landscape
so looking back
in the top left corner there you can see
the clean growth strategy which was
published in 2017
and at that point net zero was barely
even a concept and there was no debate
really around increasing ambition it was
all about reducing to a certain level on
1990 levels
so
you know looking at where we are now
considering we've got net zero in law
we're seeing the ambition being
increased to 2030 and through to 2050 as
well
there's been a lot that's happened over
these 18 months and and and so
this kind of sets out
you know and it helps to to visualize
the the amount of publications and
documents that we've received in that
space
um in
particular looking at some of the
hydrogen stuff that's come out so we've
seen a lot of industry reports looking
at the safety case
offshore integration and also uptake in
in transport and heat and those kind of
things
and we've also seen a flurry of
government documents so those documents
that are bordered in red
what has come out from government in
respect of um hydrogen
so we
around the middle of the screen i can't
point i don't think you won't see but we
had the ten point plan come out at the
end of last year and point number two on
there was hydrogen development getting
uh scale going
across the country and seeing regional
development there
we've also had a number of funding
schemes announced um
and largely in transport but also the
industrial clusters um
and some around industrial fuel
switching
and now we've had the the heat and
building strategy most recently but most
importantly in respect of hydrogen
development we had the uk hydrogen
strategy published uh just last month
and and within there there's a lot of
commitment as to
what we might need to do in order to to
get hydrogen going in the uk
um but also importantly it set out a
number of consultations that are going
to be looked at over the coming
uh months and and years in respect of
actually uh fleshing out what the what
the opportunity looks like
so yeah the hydrogen strategy itself
just a brief overview of what was in
there
really it just reaffirmed some of the
the commitments that were made in the 10
point plan um
but most importantly it's committed to
five gigawatts of production capacity by
2030.
i know from what we're hearing from
industry
they think that that could be made a
little bit higher the target could be 10
15 20 gigawatts potentially
and and some regions so looking at the
northeast and the north west they're
saying that they can meet that target by
by themselves
um
also it is set out that hydrogen could
meet around 20 to 35 percent of final
energy demand so that's a huge chunk of
of uh the future energy mix
there was also 900 million of funding
announced so a lot of this has already
been committed and it's historical but
there is some that's due to come out in
the coming months and and uh years and
we've set out some of some of that in
the in the slides a bit further along
most importantly within there it they
said that they were adopting a twin
track approach to hydrogen production so
that's looking at both blue and green
hydrogen production and i'll talk about
what that means uh later on but
um it's moving away from a debate of you
know it's either or it's all types of
hydrogen as long as it's got low carbon
content it should be suitable and
compatible with achieving net zero
um but but like i said previously a lot
of the decisions have been pushed
through to 2022 so there's a number of
consultations out at the moment
um so thinking about uh blending into
the gas grid the future of the gas
system itself those kind of things
they're being looked at and and
potentially published at the end of this
year and into 2022.
so
setting the context
around hydrogen then so
why
why is hydrogen being seen as a
potentially a big thing of the future
and potentially of the now
so
we've seen that
it's expected that hydrogen is going to
play a big part
it looks like hydrogen is able to play a
part in a number of sectors so one of
the advantages about hydrogen is that it
is versatile so you can use it across
transport across heat
you can use it in marine applications
heavy machinery and equipment
within the gas grid so there's lots of
uses for hydrogen
and i suppose one of the the key
benefits of it is that it's a green gas
and it's that's something that we don't
have currently
and the benefits of that are that
you can look at potential energy storage
look coping with seasonal demand so when
you've got a lot of offshore wind
generating in the winter months
rather than that being
wasted or curtailed you can use
that energy store it up and and use it
when when it whenever it might be needed
um
also thinking as well about the benefit
to the the system uh the general
electricity system so looking at
flexibility uh values of potential
hydrogen production and there's a range
of applications that might make it uh
potentially uh beneficial and especially
in the context of the east of england
where the electricity grid is quite
constrained and so looking at an
alternative energy source might be quite
beneficial
so
moving on to specifically how hydrogen
is produced so you might have heard a
number of colours banded about in
respect
types of hydrogen
the the primary method for producing
hydrogen at the moment in the uk is is
grey hydrogen production
so
that's typically produced through steam
methane reformation of fossil fuels
and when the hydrogen is produced
there's also co2 that's produced and
that's released into the atmosphere and
so that's not compatible with with net
zero and and so the solution uh for that
type of hydrogen production uh is blue
hydrogen which looks at capturing that
carbon that's produced in the same
process
now the
capture rates are
uncertain there's not really anything
that's proven at large scale in respect
to calm capture and storage and so
blue hydrogen is is uh
still being developed it's likely that
that's going to be pursued in the
industrial clusters thinking about the
northeast and the northwest
um but crucially
we need to ensure that that carbon is
captured if it's going to be compatible
moving forward
most interestingly i suppose is green
hydrogen which is is the gold standard
so
through electrolysis
of water you split the h2o molecule into
pure hydrogen and pure oxygen
and that way there's no carbon dioxide
that's that's produced in the process
you can use that pure oxygen pure
hydrogen as a fuel and potentially use
that oxygen
for other use cases as well
and the idea is that you would get the
electricity for electrolysis from
potentially
an offshore wind farm or onshore wind
farm or solar farm or whatever it might
be
and there's some some other colors i i
noted along the bottom i think
we're moving away from the color debate
in the uk as i mentioned earlier we're
looking more at carbon content of
hydrogen
and so we'll probably see
hydrogen produced from from nuclear and
pyrolysis clusters low carbon hydrogen
moving forwards
so
yeah looking at the range of
applications so we we've touched on this
all already in part so
the fact that so looking top to a top
left corner with clean power generation
so you can
electricity if you wanted to
uh to create power at times of need
um commercial buildings so often have
large natural gas demand you could use
the the green hydrogen gas to fuel some
of the
the the boilers there and and the same
goes for for homes
um and and heat systems
and also looking more broadly at
transport so we'll probably see uptake
in and the heavier end of the market
with transport so thinking about those
hgvs construction vehicles
um
trains in particular particular areas
where where it's not viable to electrify
we think the passenger car market is
probably going to be predominantly
electric so we're already seeing a lot
of
movement there in that respect and the
previous speaker
mentioned
around about the the potential
with electric there
um and also energy storage i mentioned
earlier on the the value in
using renewables in the summer time that
would otherwise not be used and and
storing that energy to be used in the
winter months
so
looking in
a little bit more depth so looking at
transport specifically so we think this
is going to be one of the
uh early movers
particularly in the east of england
given the the barriers we have to
um
given its largely rural area and there's
barriers in terms of uh traveling long
distances and having access to a to a
charging network
you might see some of those heavier uh
vehicles and those long distance
transport uh applications uh uptake
hydrogen i suppose one of the advantages
is that you would refuel as you would um
a normal petrol and diesel car today so
it's within two or three minutes
um
and the range that you get as a result
of that could be three four five hundred
miles so typical to what we what we see
today
and so looking at that heavier end of
the market that's quite advantageous if
if you need something that's quick and
and that can take you take you those
long distances
so the idea is that we would start to
see a cross-country refueling network um
uh
uh come into come into play
the the cost savings will be
obviously derived as a result of uh
getting more vehicles converted to
hydrogen and scaling up that network
across the country
and there's funding like i mentioned
earlier on around
specific applications and demonstration
projects for for hydrogen vehicles
across the country at the moment
and and also we have the transport
decarbonization plan which sets out uh
the options for hydrogen in in that
heavier vehicle end of the market moving
forwards
and i think actually appended to the to
the slides if they're circulated
afterwards we've listed listed some of
those funding
opportunities and some of those schemes
that are currently ongoing that you
could look to potentially get involved
in
moving forward so looking at the role in
heat as well so that's probably an
another big area that we may or may not
see
local businesses and local
homeowners
experience some kind of impact
so
at the moment it like i said it's unsure
as to to what extent hydrogen will play
a part in in decarbonizing heat
there's a number of feasibility studies
that are underway looking at whether
it's safe whether it's reliable whether
it can perform in a similar way to
the way that natural gas does today
and the idea is if we look on the right
hand side of the screen here looking at
that hydrogen blending into the gas
network
so currently today
the permitted levels of hydrogen blend
into the gas grid is 0.1
so very very small
the idea is that
the current gas grid could cope with
blends of up to 20
especially with the current upgrade
works going on and so the next step
would be to allow blends up to 20 within
the gas grid and and
start decarbonizing
uh heat that's heat that homes use
obviously that's only part of the way
that there's still 80 then that needs to
be decarbonized and
that would be
almost a
you wouldn't get gradual blending of 20
then 40 than 50 for example that's
purely limited by the fact that the uh
grid infrastructure at the moment uh
that there's currently still a fair few
steel pipelines so i think we're around
65 to 70 complete in respect of
upgrading those pipelines into
polyethylene pipelines which basically
plastic pipes
which don't fracture when hydrogen flows
through flows through the material
whereas with with steel pipelines given
hydrogen is a very small molecule it can
cause steel embrittlement within the
pipeline
which could cause leaks and cracks and
those kind of things so
the the gap between 20 and 100 is purely
making sure that
um the infrastructure is in place to
allow that and also that it it's safe
and possible
so
the government's announced its intention
to support a hydrogen neighborhood trial
by 2023
i think we're seeing
that that's going to be in
gateshead up in the north
and potentially a larger scale by 2025
looking at a hydrogen village
and there's also mentioned as well now
of a hydrogen town by 2030
so we'll wait to see see what happens
there
um
the
government's working with hse to to get
blends of 20 enabled by 2023 so actually
quite soon
that there's a number of studies that
have been completed now and
um we've kept track of all of those on
on our website so if you wanted to to go
and have a look at what's been done and
where we're at um i recommend going and
having a look there
and i mentioned as well that there's a
number of call for evidences out and in
2022 the government's going to look at
mandating hydrogen-ready appliances
so right now if you install a gas boiler
it's um not necessarily able to take a
hydrogen blend
for a it's a tiny tiny cost to
make sure that any future boiler that's
being replaced through its natural
process
is a very very tiny uh step and cost to
actually make that boiler hydrogen ready
for the future so
if we do see a hydrogen gas grid
moving forwards you would be well placed
as a homeowner and as a business to
um to take a hydrogen that comes through
the grid for heating and whatever it
might be
and there's that consultation that's
launching later this year looking at
what role the gas grid is expected to
play
um and what areas it might touch
specifically
so
taking it then and looking at norfolk
and suffolk so
a lot of this is um
national hype and national hope
but what is it that is special about
norfolk and suffolk
and what is it about norfolk and suffolk
that might be different to other regions
and where might we start to see
um
uh early uptake and across what sectors
so
we know that
the east of england is already
an energy powerhouse so we we have uh
lots of offshore wind and lots more
coming online in the future
we've also got the the gas terminal
which which brings around 20 to 30
percent of of uk uh gas uh through
onshore
we've also got new nuclear coming in at
suffolk and potentially essex
and so
there's this clear potential here for
blue green whatever color of hydrogen
you might want
to be produced in the future
so
in theory the east of england looks well
placed to go about producing hydrogen
the issue comes
more with where
you might send that hydrogen so where
does the demand come from obviously if
we enable 20 blends within the gas grid
that's the start and that gives a
potential off-take
but what we don't see
in the east of england which we do see
in
industrial clusters up in the northeast
or the northwest
is a large industrial load
so we have
energy intensive operations across the
region in quite a dispersed
distribution but we don't have that
central point where we can channel
hydrogen demand and so that's why we
haven't necessarily seen
development here as we have seen in
other regions across the uk
and so
the way we see it developing is this
approach to
this bottom-up approach to demand
aggregation
so looking at where
there might be a cluster of fleets or a
cluster of hydrogen applications that
might enable you to
create a hydrogen demand anchor to
warrant creating a hydrogen supply in
the future
and so some of the the potential sources
of demand in across suffolk so we
probably see
a role for a few demo projects with with
local authority uh waste wagons so often
heavy vehicles
uh going out on on for long uh durations
and also for for wider road transport so
looking at some of the
the large buses across the region um
especially in norfolk there's quite an
old aging fleet of buses and it might be
a good opportunity to trial some
hydrogen buses there and also some of
the hgvs that travel those long
distances so travel across the country
and over to europe through through the
ports along the east coast
there's also in the east of england this
use case that isn't spoken about too
much but looking at agriculture
and and you know agricultural processes
require large heavy machinery that is
still burning diesel
and so
looking at potentially applying hydrogen
in that particular use case could be
something that's quite niche about this
region and something that isn't being
explored elsewhere and potentially
something that can make a huge dent in
in overall emissions
and also in construction of big projects
so size will see is there is listed
there as
as a as an example but
reducing that embedded carbon in
developments and actually having
hydrogen forklifts um hydrogen uh
waste wagons or whatever it might be
um
and actually reducing the emissions of
of whatever the new development might be
looking as well
over
potentially decarbonizing trains so
looking at hydrogen trains
we're
in quite a unique position in the east
of england in that
network rail has flagged some of the
east coast lines for hydrogen conversion
and and
looking at
batteries aren't necessarily suitable to
travel the long distances that are
required and electrification isn't
necessarily financially viable and so
network rail is looking at potentially
conversion converting some of those
lines along the east coast to hydrogen
decarbonizing some of the energy
intensive processes so looking at sugar
beat processing um or even breweries
which have large gas demand and are
often carbon point sources across the
region
blending into some of the the region's
combined cycle gas turbine plants so
looking at
where you might be able to uh well a
good example is is the great yarmouth
ccgt which
actually can take a 50 blend of hydrogen
today
um and that would significantly slash
the emissions and the amount of carbon
that's emitted through that process
and also looking at ports ports are
actually quite interesting given that
there's a congregation of different
demands at ports
so you have things like the marine
vessels
you have uh rail networks which which
pass uh through the the ports and
between ports
you've obviously got all the the heavy
uh goods vehicles that pass through from
europe and across to the midlands and
down to the southwest
and also some of that port side
equipment as well looking at forklifts
and and similar machinery looking at how
you might
use hydrogen for those applications as
well
and also
fundamentally heat for home
heating homes and heating businesses
across the region looking at where
hydrogen might be able to play a part
there
i've got a little timer on my screen
which says
i've got seven minutes left so i'll try
and speed through the last few slides
this really is just
a demonstration of how we might look to
um aggregate demand and we've developed
a mapping portal which is helping us to
do this
so looking at some of the physical
networks here so this is the the major
road network across the region
um also
popping on here the the railways so we
can see the split of electric versus
diesel railway lines
and those ones that travel north to
south down to london typically tend to
be electrified those ones that are
traveling east to west are those that
tend to be
diesel-powered locomotives
and it's those
lines so that the line that goes up to
chroma and those lines along the east
suffolk
um
coast that have been flagged by network
rail for for hydrogen conversion
um
we've been looking specifically at
the using historic landfill sites which
are currently
in many cases
wasted wastelands which can't be
developed upon we're looking at the
potential to actually site solar pv on
those
in those areas alongside an electrolyzer
to produce hydrogen which could be
used for for local transport fleets
so if i pop on here
um looking at some of the licensed
landfill sites so we know that there's
regular visits and present day visits
from some of the waste wagons that are
attending those sites there's a
potential demand there
similarly for recycling centres which
have a number of large vehicles going uh
to and from
interestingly as well uh waste water
treatment plants so
not only is there a large energy demand
as part of the processes there there's
also fleets going to and from which
could potentially be
hydrogen powered
but interestingly as well in the
wastewater treatment process
oxygen pure oxygen is is a key part
that's required and so in producing
green hydrogen you could make a case for
using both the pure hydrogen that's
produced but also the pure oxygen and
you can probably think of another of a
number of other use cases for for that
oxygen as well thinking about hospitals
potentially even scuba diving and simply
similar things across
along the coast
and so
our approach really is is is thinking
about how you might congregate some of
these demands to anchor that initial
hydrogen supply
and also looking at some of the existing
generators across the region so we know
in parts of norfolk and especially
suffolk
renewable generators can be paid to turn
off
due to grid constraints and sometimes
curtailment so times that generators
aren't aren't producing energy or are
producing energy but can't export it
that can be more than 20 of their of
their operation time in a year so it's a
huge amount of energy that's wasted that
you could look at potentially using to
produce hydrogen in times that
the energy can't be exported to the grid
to to use for some of these these wider
demand cases across the region
so
lowest of power park is an example of
how we've we've used some of this
mapping work i'm conscious of time so i
won't speak
too much about this but basically we
there's a
many of you will know the gulliver
onshore wind turbine at the power park
site that's coming to a point where it
either needs to be
repowered or
redeveloped
and so using that that redeveloped
turbine to potentially produce hydrogen
to fuel some of the local demands is
something that we've been looking at
so if i move on to the next slide we've
zoomed in and looked at a potential
potential use cases across the immediate
region so looking at the first bus depot
which is immediately next door in the
top right of that map
um looking at some of uh east suffolk
council's fleets but also suffolk county
council's fleets as well
some of that non-road mobile machinery
so around the port there's a fair bit of
that you could look at potentially uh
using hydrogen there
some of the crew transfer
vessels so those that are maintaining
offshore wind farms also some of those
larger service vessels that could also
uh be hydrogen powered
and also some of that haulage so you've
got the a4 47 there that's passing
passing by you could potentially see um
well you do see a large number of hgvs
pass from the port and through over to
the midlands and down to london so you
could look at a refueling infrastructure
that would would help to decarbonize
that entire network and also there's a
rail siding there that we we've
highlighted in yellow that is
potentially something that could site
solar and potentially site an
electrolyzer to to produce hydrogen and
refuel
some of these um these applications
and also the weary line i should mention
is is one of those lines that's been
flagged by network rail for hydrogen
conversion
i did have an example here for suffolk
as well so we've looked at
where some of those uh energy intensive
users are in berries in edmonds as an
example so we've got the the anglian
water large waste water treatment plant
north just north of berries and edmonds
and we also have
sugar beet processing
um
which is a high gas user currently
purely through the process of of drying
drying out the sugar beet
and also the brewery there as well which
is also a large gas demand
we know that within the region there's
more than 100 medium and large fleet
vehicles
and we know that along that stretch of
road so you can see based on the color
coding the darker red the shade the more
heavy goods vehicles there are that pass
through
you can see that there's around
six to eight thousand um hgvs passing
through there each day along that
stretch of the a14 coming from the ports
um and over to the midlands so
potentially a good point to to put some
refueling infrastructure
we know also the immediate areas are
surrounded by farmland so again there's
that agricultural agricultural option
for using the hydrogen
and we know as well
gateway 14 um is part of the the
freeport east bid so with felix stowe
and harrich
you might see maybe hydrogen production
over at gateway 14 uh refueling some of
the hgvs and vehicles that pass through
also some some applications for for
refueling vessels and that kind of thing
as well
so
this is a very niche example but clearly
a a good example of how you might start
to aggregate that demand across the
region
now i'm very conscious of time so just
to
flash up this briefly this is our
network vision for the the east so this
is how we see it playing out
um looking at some of the generation
assets but some of the demand off takes
it across the region
also and uh in respect of next steps so
we're currently looking at potentially
developing a new anglia hydrogen
strategy so working with the lep and
some of the local councils and some of
those key regional stakeholders
looking at what we should be doing uh
from the perspective of the yeast to
actually get the east of england on the
map or on the hydrogen map and get
things moving here
we've got a number of projects that are
underway so we're looking at the lowest
off power park um schnetterton clean
transport hub that's a
historical landfill site that might be
able to host renewables and produce
hydrogen on a strategic part of the a11
the freeport e stuff that we just
mentioned but also the baxter energy hub
and there's some some ongoing work
streams there looking at how hydrogen
might be produced and sent through the
gas distribution system
we've launched the the or we're going to
launch the net zero mapping tool which
is a way of visualizing these
opportunities across the east and
looking at how we might aggregate those
demands
and on the the far right i suppose the
ultimate thing that we want to be doing
here is getting projects on the ground
so
what can we do to place the east of
england well for future funding rounds
specifically the net zero hydrogen fund
which is launching next year um and so
how can we make sure that the east of
england is ready to go in terms of
putting a pitch in for something like
that
so
that's everything i had to go through um
i'm not sure how we've done for time but
potentially uh we can take questions now
or we or we can go on to the panel
session
um you've covered that really well
indeed and we'll have some questions for
you i'm sure in a few moments because as
you rightly say you're part of the panel
we have
assembling very soon on on the stage
here thank you very much indeed just in
case uh you're wondering if we're still
with you we'll give you all a big round
of applause
[Applause]